sur ce plateau jean claude félix
tchicaya chercheurs à l'ipp seul
institut prospective sécurité en europe
spécialiste de l'afrique bonjour la
famille gnassingbé est à la tête du togo
depuis cinquante trois ans est ce qu'il
ya une forme de résignation dans le pays
ou pas du tout non peut pas dire qu'il
ya une forme de résignation pour
l'ensemble des togolais ils sont un peu
plus de lui millions plus de trois
millions de togolais vont aller de ma
voter certains ont pâte dans les voter
puis une bonne partie sans être résignés
se pose des questions sur est-ce que la
véracité des chiffres qui vont être
données en termes de résultats vont être
véritable est ce qu'ils vont vraiment
être représentatifs de la réalité
justement est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à
des fraudes électorales est ce que là
l'élection sera supervisée coûte de
l'opinion internationale
alors il ya l'opinion internationale
africaine l'union africaine la cedeao
sur le plan de la région il ya des
diplomaties en dehors du continent qui
sont à peu près une centaine donc il ya
à peu près une plus d'une heure plus de
500 personnes
observateur de l'extérieur du togo qui
seront sur les 9000 bureau mais il est
lui un coup théâtre et un incident
notoire pour une organisation de la
société civile il y en a à peu près 18
qui veulent être observateur du nk été
assez puissante et bien représentative
de la société civile qui a été depuis ce
mercredi donc interdite de faire valoir
son droit à l'observation des élections
sous l'égide de leurs organisations de
société civile pour observer le scrutin
et comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
cette exclusion et bien elle a
interprété de deux manières est ce que
c'est encore une matinée une fois le
pouvoir qu'ils resserrent
un scrutin qui n'est pas démocratique le
togo n'est pas un pays démocratique
la première des ambitions des togolais
sait que lille est un développement
démocratique qui sortent de d'un
quotidien en apnée depuis 53 ans son
père est arrivé au pouvoir en 67 la
quitter par la biologie donc la mort en
2005 il est arrivé au pouvoir nommé par
l'assemblée nationale et l'armée
il s'est donc nous représenter deux fois
là il a changé la constitution en mai en
mai dernier pour se représenter deux
fois dont vous voyez donc si c'est
pratiquement une vie entière avec le
même nom à l'intérieur au sommet de
l'état la famille eyadéma donc est ce
que l'alternance est possible pour les
togolais
l'histoire politique du togo est
émaillée jonché de violence politique de
répression
mais il ya des oppositions des élites
qui travaille et il est ce qu'on peut
dire oui sur le plan économique pourtant
tout est là le pétrole l'or
le mague annese le phosphate
on peut dire aussi que 0,6 pour cent du
personnel sur le plan extractif
représente la société civile et active
du togo et est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
à des violences post électorales
je n'espère pas j'espère que les
oppositions s'y adonnent faire leur
travail soit quelque chose soir
pacifique
il ya eu à chaque fois sur le plan post
électorales ou pré électorale des
centaines de morts la campagne depuis 15
jours il n'y a pas eu de trouble et deux
heures
manifeste il ya des chiffres quand même
pour nuancer ce que je viens de dire
il ya les chiffres quand même sur le
plan macroéconomique qui de john qui
nuance un petit peu le bilan de fin de
de fin de règne j'allais dire de me sèye
adema fort fils qui serait quand même
pas on pourrait considérer comme une
embellie mais cela ne suffit pas sur les
500 mille emplois premier les
infrastructures et industriels ne sont
pas ne sont pas debout
donc il va falloir beaucoup plus pour
tirer positivement les ambitions de tout
un peuple de plus de 80 personnes c'est
loin de la fin merci jean félix tchicaya
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur ali ps
spécialiste de l'afrique